and from this wednesday we want to  encourage people to take more and even  unlimited amounts of outdoor exercise  you can sit in the sun  in your local park you can drive to  other destinations  you can even play sports only with  members of your own household  you must obey the rules on social  distancing and to enforce those rules we  will increase the fines  for the small minority who break them  and so every day with ever increasing  data  we will be monitoring the r and the  number of new infections  and the progress we are making  and if we as a nation begin to fulfill  the conditions i have set out  then in the next few weeks and months  we may be able to go further